I want to play a voicemail for you today
remember we have a voicemail number 2192
David P that will show you how quickly
bad information spreads
yesterday during an NFL football game an
NFL player named Demar Hamlin
collapsed after taking a hit he was on
defense seemed to take a hit sort of to
the left chest and stood up and then
collapsed the game was called off the
latest news that I have as of this
particular moment and I should make sure
that it's accurate as of right now he is
in critical condition
um and we we don't know exactly what his
uh prognosis is DeMar Hamlin uh we're
hoping for the best
immediately there's speculation on
Twitter that he collapsed and died
because of the covet vaccine and I
didn't think this would reach our
audience But Eric from Mass right away
called in about it take a listen to this
hey David you believe yet it's Eric from
Mass
um guy gets died on the field from the
vaccine and no he didn't die
he's alive and we're hoping he will
survive he did not die but it was not
from the vaccine
rest in peace
guy just died on the field for the
vaccine in an NFL game uh never happened
before
has never happened
um you look like a ghost since you've
been sick yeah actually what's funny is
we had an issue with our white balance
last week I did look like a ghost but it
had nothing to do with covet we fixed
the issue um I've never seen something I
mean so wipe my life
um and you did this you you told people
to get it
and you'll be held accountable for that
I mean I don't know if it'll be through
the law but morally you're gonna have to
live with the fact that you told people
to get poisoned I mean
but you probably don't matter to you so
whatever but I'm just figured I'd let
you know to my hand went dead at 24
Monday Night Football collapsed and died
on the fields in a vaccine rest in peace
yeah so again he's he's alive
um you know the the sad thing about this
is
uh we have so much information so so
first of all
we don't know Demar Hamlin's vaccination
status first of all so even the
assumption that he's vaccinated is one
that is not based in fact but of course
this is the new thing conspiracies tend
to shift over time and the new thing now
is this the the phrase they're using is
suddenly died and the story that's being
told is young people suddenly dying from
the covet vaccine even though there is
not actually evidence of that and um for
a lot of people they don't care that
there's no evidence of it and I think
Eric from Mass falls under that um
category now there's going to be a lot
of time to figure out exactly what
happened with Demar Hamlin but the best
explanations that are speculative of
course that I've seen so far are that
when you get hit I forget the name of
the condition but when you get hit hard
in the left chest blunt force to the
left chest
if that hit happens
coinciding with the particular moment in
the heart rhythm it can cause exactly
this and it can be very serious we don't
yet know the number one concern right
now is DeMar Hamlin's Health but
um when we have better explanations
when people go to vaccine vaccine
vaccine even in the absence of evidence
that Hamlin was vaccinated I hope that
nobody in my audience
is going to fall for that type of thing
and we saw some of it on Twitter
so I saw some tweets sent to me and
here's a voicemail from Eric from from
Mass
um this is what happened is really scary
but the speed with which baseless
disinformation spreads is also really
really scary when all you have is a
hammer in this case the hammer is
vaccines are bad everything looks like a
nail my my camera white balance problem
last week was because I got a covet
vaccine rather than my camera was doing
something weird
uh football player collapses that was
the vaccine do we even know he was
vaccinated well we don't but it must
have been the vaccine
don't fall for this stuff
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we're going to talk about the
fight for the speakership among
Republicans and uh votes coming soon we
will know who the speaker will be very
soon we are going to try to figure out
what is happening in China with kovid
there are reports of bodies piling up
crematoria overwhelmed it's crazy what's
going on and we're going to talk about
States raising their minimum wages in
2023 where can workers expect higher pay
where are the wages going even higher in
2024 we have the list we will talk about
it we will tell you all of those stories
and more when I am joined by producer
Pat from Florida
on the bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money sir
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves as bad sir yes sir all of
that and more on the bonus show sign up
at joinpakman.com and remember that next
Wednesday January 11th at 6 Eastern we
are doing the next David packman show
Town Hall it will be streaming live so
anyone who wants to watch it can watch
it
anyone who wants to participate can
participate via Discord and our members
get Priority Access via Discord so sign
up at joinpakman.com coupon code 24
starts now it's 2023 and it is great to
be back